um 617 607 830 4750 we've got time for a
couple more calls next callers from the
504 area code caller what is your name
and where you calling from hey this is
sean from baton rouge baton rouge
louisiana awesome what is on your mind
today I got a quick comment and a rather
serious question okay go ahead that
could be one of the biggest unbroken
stories there is I'm ready ok I'll start
with the quick comment one is about your
hair ok you know you could support the
LGBT cube community by putting a little
rib au in it wearing lipstick and being
miss pac-man for a day ok we have a meme
like that there isn't there is a miss
pac-man dundas floating around alright
I'm bracing for the blockbuster Stoller
is based on a comment what's the story
that you are going to break ok so there
are some art t links that I've strange
about it and put on Twitter on my
Twitter I'm from the lost forgotten
channel you know a little small youtube
channel and um here's the gist of it in
2009 Gaddafi went to moscow to meet with
Putin and Sergei Lavrov to discuss a
deal with Rosneft shortly afterward
russia began building a base near a
certain town in Libya that you might
have heard of called Benghazi and while
this seems like a big connection it
never gets mentioned but what actually
represents is a decades-long support of
international terrorism by Vladimir
Putin through Gaddafi okay and the
Soviet regime in general
alright and then which is so but most of
this is known isn't it I mean at what's
the blockbuster aspect of it yeah its
individual known facts but you would
think that daring stay 11 hours of a
Hillary Clinton hearing they might have
mentioned that but what do you think is
Clark liner get emails inch community
we're probably giving support the
Hillary Clinton because she didn't
sacrificed American strategic standpoint
which was not to provoke Russia yeah by
complaining about this in flick and she
took kind of you know a really
self-defeating position for country
during that hearing and not a lot of
people realize it so let me see I just
want to make sure I understand what
Russia your your suggestion is that this
campaign of funding terror by Vladimir
Putin and Russia didn't come up during
the Benghazi hearings with Hillary
Clinton because she was being supported
by some of the same financial elements
is that generally the idea no no no
because because she's a patriot yeah and
because of the fast Republican
connections to Russian oligarchs that
have basically wasted about a hundred
and fifty million dollars holding
committee F hearing after committee
hearing against Hillary Clinton while
the whole time that's not even
discussing the fact that Gaddafi was
hopped up by the Soviet Union and then
Vladimir Putin and even it goes far back
as Sylvia twangs being used by Irish
Republican Army terrorists okay that
they got from Gaddafi Pat how are you
feeling about it's like a long
historical weather seems got even
brushed over yeah okay well listen we're
going to look into it I think it's
interesting let's it's a little bit to
look into yes are y'all good looking
it's a mouthful we'll check it out
alright thank you so much for the
all I appreciate it that's it for today
as far as phone calls go 617 830 47 50 s
always the number we will take more
calls again next week